i'm directing my team to work with
pfizer to double our order from 10
million to 20 million treatment courses
on testing
i know this remains frustrating believe
me it's frustrating to me
but we're making improvements
in the last two weeks we've stood up
federal testing sites all over the
country
president biden yesterday trying to ease
anxiety over the pandemic as the u.s
shatters the global single day record
this week with more than a million new
cases reported monday the fast spread of
infections is creating chaos for air
travel and leading to hours-long waits
times for testing let's bring in admiral
brett jarrar he is a former white house
coronavirus task force member and you
are the testing czar
i wanted to listen to the back and forth
with the white house yesterday um this
is jen's hockey closes this out but this
is what they said they were going to do
on testing and where she says we are
today watch
we don't have it all right it basically
she says this the first delivery from
manufacturers will start later this
month and obviously then we will work to
get it out the door as quickly as
possible this is in regards to the fact
that they said right before christmas
they would get 500 million tests out to
americans but admiral by the time they
get those tests to americans it is
likely that the omicron surge will be
likely behind us at that point
yes you're exactly correct i think the
problem we have right now is there was a
lack of federal orders for tests between
january and september so as we saw the
industry really cratered the
manufacturing lines were taken down the
people were laid off and now we're
really behind the eight ball but we are
where we are right now you are correct
that 500 million tests
if you look at the government's rfp
that's going to be over three months so
that's really a drop in the bucket so
what we really need to do now is use
those tests smartly and i see no
indication that the administration is
doing that you talked about isolation
everyone who tests positive you could
send them one of those tests so they
could test at day five we should be
sending it to the elderly and those with
comorbid conditions so that they could
test early and get the pfizer or the
merc drug but we're seeing no indication
of leadership we're just seeing more
confusing guidelines from the cdc it
really is as shocking and the the cdc is
the centers for disease control you need
the public to be able to trust them and
then the president said this again
yesterday it's call for two this is
where he said something he said hundreds
of times before i took exception to it
watch here
there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
so we got to make more progress
and for patients who still haven't
gotten your kids vaccinated please get
them vaccinated
does that still hold water i mean i have
double backs booster and i had my flu
shot and i spent christmas weeks sicker
than i've been in in decades so and then
i'm aging
dating myself a little bit there but
i really am glad that i have the
vaccines i know it kept me out of the
hospital or even possible death but this
is not just about the unvaccinated
anymore if everybody can spread it
you're exactly right i want everybody to
know that getting vaccinated and
particularly with omicron getting a
booster is very important to your
protection especially if you're elderly
or high risk but you are correct because
omicron
circumvents immunity both vaccine and
natural immunity
you know people in the hospital now they
won't tell you the figures but i'm sure
that a majority of the people in the
hospital have at least been vaccinated
doubly
and we all know people who've gotten the
booster and are still getting omicron so
i think it's a disservice to say it's
just by the unvaccinated because it's
telling the vaccinated that you don't
have a problem you're not subject to
omicron and that's false so it's not
only incorrect information i think it's
doing a disservice to public health by
blaming it on the unvaccinated people
this is a problem we all have to face
vaccinated unvaccinated we need to get
our booster we need to have plans that
if we do get sick particularly in a
high-risk group that we can get
antibodies or we can get those oral
antiviral therapies it's one of those
things where you know
the government needs to step up but what
you're saying here is that we see no
signs
of that no urgency
recycled
i mean look at the cdc new
recommendation
after five days if you could find a test
and if you want one then go take an
antigen test that's not a recommendation
how about when you'd say well if you
could find a vaccine and you want to
take one take one no make a
recommendation and the recommendation
should be that after five days if you
are going to be in a high-risk situation
if you're a food server if you work in
hospitals
if you're going to be around a lot of
people you should take a test before you
leave the home in the united kingdom
it's seven days of isolation followed by
two sequential antigen tests that makes
sense but when we're having a million
cases and remember that million cases is
probably underestimated by three we're
having three million new cases a day we
have to be cautious and taking a test to
get out of isolation seems incredibly
reasonable and the government can fix
this send tests to the people who are
positive state and local health
departments know who they are right well
you must as the former testings are it
must frustrate you to see all these
lines we have pictures from all over the
country people standing line for hours
to try to get a test admiral brett
gerard thank you we'll stay in touch